では よろしくお願いします
今日はあの まあ決断力というテーマでね
お釈迦様の言葉から我々はどうやって判断すればよろしいかというね
判断の まあ何と言いますかね
判断のからくりというか
やり取りというか まあこの技をね
身につくる方法ということで話したいと思っていましたが
まあ結局はその話す必要はないとも思いますよ
なぜかというと もう判断しなきゃ生きていられませんだからね
正しく まだまだ生きていらっしゃるんだから
まあ結構立派に判断して生きてきたんじゃないかなと
とにかく生きているということだからね
だから判断はそれなりになさって生きてきているんだけど
わざわざ今更言わなくたってもね
まあいいんじゃないかなと思います
幸福には生きている あ
そうですか まあそんなに不幸のどん底にいるとまたかえって思わないんだからね
あまりにも不幸でたまらんだったら
ここまで来られませんしね
まあ結構暇があったんじゃないかなと
だから暇があったということは幸福ということだからね
決して悪いことではないし
余裕があったということだからね
そんなもんで 人生っていうのは大体いつでも何か判断しなくちゃいけないんですよ
これは私で大人だけではなくて
こちら子供一人しかいませんですけどね
でまあもうそれでも判断しなきゃ生きていられないんですよ
あれこれと 判断が間違っちゃうと
いろいろ悩んだり泣いたりすることにもなるし
子供の場合は叱られたりとかね
怒鳴られたりすることにもなるし
それは判断が間違った時
判断が正しかった時はよく褒められて褒めてくれるがいい子だと
で 我々大人も同じことでね
ずっといろいろ判断しながら生きてきたんですよ
もしもう判断間違いっていうのはね
したならば これで人生は終わっちゃうんですよ
ということは 判断のミスっていうのは大変なことで
死んでしまいますよ  それなりに皆様方が聞けば
そんな立派に判断している覚えがないと思っているかもしれません
いろいろ失敗はしましたと
でも生きてるんだから
まあどうったらろくな失敗ではないと思いますね
まあそれほどもう大事になる失敗ではない
まあどこかでまあ左に曲がるところをちょっと右に曲がってちょっと歩いてみたと
見たところで様子が違うので
やっぱり違うんだと やっぱり右に行こうかと
小さなことはあっても
我々は一応生きているということは
そんなに大胆な判断ミスをしているわけじゃないんです
で 言いたいのは いつでも判断しなくちゃいけない人生なんです
流されて生きるということはできないんです
そういうことだから 一応もうちょっとしっかりと判断できたならば
しっかりと生きていられるということにはなります
だから 我々の人生の評価っていうのは
自分の判断したその採点によります
自分が大変立派じゃないと思うならば
もうほとんど立派な判断はしたことではありませんし
で これはまあいろんなところでまあもうあることで
人生全体的なことなんです
健康で明るく 豊かで生きていられるという
どちらでも判断なんですよ
健康が悪くなっちゃって
体が病弱になるということも
どこかで判断ミスをしているということなんです
まあ生まれて生まれてからもうやっぱり体の調子が悪いと弱いというならば
もう過去で判断ミスを犯したということになるんです
生まれる前に それは今更どうすることもできないかもしれませんだけど
どうせ判断ミスしたら結果はどうすることもできないんですよ
悪い結果になるんです
で 私たちの生き方は健康であるか
明るく生きているか 豊かでしょうか
もういろいろ人間関係で問題あるかないか
幸福で生きていられるかとかね
これ全て私がどのように判断するかっていうことの結果なんです
だから一人一人の判断の能力っていうのは
自分で自分の人生を見てみると
どんな生き方をしているんでしょうかと振り返ってみると
見事にわかるんですよ
だから まずそのポイントを覚えてほしい
時々いるんですよ すごく頭はいいと
しっかり物事を考えている人やと言いながら
自分の間違いでも ちょっとこれ間違っているんではないかと言ったら
あんた何者かと 私はここまで勉強しているんではないかという態度で怒ったりはしたりする場合もあります
しかし それは良くないんですよ
自分の人生が幸福で幸せで成功しているんでしょうかと
たとえ知識人であろうとも
人生は成功していないならば
もうそっちものすごい派手に判断ミスをしているんですね
それだったら たとえ子供にでも何か言われたら真面目に聞くしかないんですよ
ですから この人生の成功の具合度合いっていうのは
自分の判断の度合いを表しているものなんです
そういうことだから これはとても大事なことなんですね
正しい判断するということは
で いくらかこの感想みたいな
こういうところを考えてほしいといういくつかの文章がございまして
日和見っていうのは私は初めて聞く言葉なんですけど
日和見主義で事なかれ主義などというものはあるんじゃないかなと
自分自身の決断行為を放棄して
投止してしまい 逃避してしまい
人の顔色をうかがう 長いものに巻かれる
郷に入れば入っては郷に従えなどの言葉のように
他人の判断に無批判に盲信して決定してしまう場合もあると
そこでこちらで訴えているのは
そうやっても他人の判断に自分が盲信してしまったと
いわゆる自分で判断しなかったというニュアンスなんです
大体みんなそう思っているんだから
私にそういうポイントを考えてほしいということなんです
で 他人の顔色を見て生きるということは
自分で判断しないという生き方じゃないんです
自分で判断しているんです
だからやっぱりその場合でも自己責任なんですよ
人の顔色を見て決めたところで
もううまくいかなかったと
大失敗しましたと だったら自分の責任ですよ
あなた方は言われたんだから
あなた方やっていたんだからやったんだよと言っても
こうやって責任逃れはできない
だから我々は判断するためには
やっぱり他人の顔色をうかがうということもしているんです
だから問題は判断するために
他人の顔色は正しい材料になるかということだけであって
それで我々はみんなやっているんだからやっているんではないかといって
それでそれで失敗したところでまた文句を
しかし 人は自分で判断しているんです
うん だから無批判に盲信に決定するということは
その人の判断基準なんです
で 人がどうやっているんでしょうかと見て
ああ では私もそうやりますよと
これは本当はあんまりにもダサい気持ち悪い生き方ですけど
もう見てみると結構やっています
であまりこの私に近いと
私はそこら辺見えますから
私は個人的にすごく気持ち悪いんですね
人の判断を見て 自分もやる場合は
ではからかってやるぞといろんな微妙にからかうんです
でも結果は相手に対してはすごく厳しいんですけど
気づかないんです 時々レストランで何か食べるものを決めると
相手あんたどちらどちらですか？と
その人がじゃあ私もと
最初からそれを読めると
相手が全く食べられないものを決めるんです
私の場合は それでも堂々と選ぶんですよ
選んで食えないのにすごく苦労しているんです
でもこれ かなりいじめられてるとは気がつかないんです
はい  まあ人の意見に耳を傾けるのは良いことですが
全くの借り物の決断だと
後になって責任を取れなくなったり
行動がぐちゃぐちゃ ちぐはぐになったりしますと
同じポイントなんですけど
人の意見聞いたら はい
わかりましたとそのままやってしまったところで
うまくいかなくなっちゃって
自分で責任持てなくなったりとかね
これ結局は自分決めたんだから
やっぱり自分で責任持たなくちゃいけないんです
私は人に頼んで あの人を殺しなさいよと言ったところで
その人はその人を殺したならば
自分で責任持たなくちゃいけないんですよ
で 命じたということは
私の判断で それでもう法律裁判になってくると
もう命令した分は私は罰を受けるし
実行した人は実行の罰を受けますよ
あの人は人の判断に乗っただけだから無罪にしましょうという話は世の中でないんですよ
だったら誰も犯罪として扱えなくなっちゃいますからね
責任を持つ人は誰もいなくなっちゃいますからね
それはありません それからトラブルが起きないようにということばかり心配してね
事なかれ主義になっちゃうんだ
それで臆病で消極的な決断しかできない状態にもなりますと
それも困りますと これもよく見ると判断なんですよ
トラブルは起こしたくないという判断なんです
だから見て見ぬ見て見ぬふりしようではないかといわれる事なかれ主義ですね
それが判断です それで消極的に臆病になったことは結果なんです
これで文句言ったって
もう結果出ているんだから
で それはどうしようもない
自分ではもう判断しているんです
で 理屈の順番では並べてないんですけど
まあ一応ある順番で それから何か判断する場合は
結果がわかるんだったらすごい便利ですね
こういう判断をしたらこんな結果になる
こういう判断をしたらこんな結果になるとわかったところで
良い結果になるようにと判断することはできます
しかし 結果は後からですからね
それはわからないんですよ
そういうことで困ったりする
どうなるでしょうかというね
で 結果は先に知る方法はないのかと
それは因果関係なんですね
だから私たちはやっぱり明日のことはわからないんだと
という立場で だからやってみなきゃわからないという
ことにするか まあどうでもいいんだから何かに判断したりはしますね
それで後で結果が悪かったらまた悩んだりもする
で これが正しくないんですよ
因果っていうのはぎっしりしたもう絶対的な法則なんです
全くも変わらないんです
いわゆるエクセプションという例外はないんです
この宇宙の中で この人生の中で何一つも例外はないんです
すべて厳密に因果法則によって
もうぎっしりと起きているものなんです
だから この結果はわからないというのはありえないんですよ
まあ問題は 我々は因果法則を馬鹿にしている
それだけのこと だから因果法則を馬鹿にしないで見てみると
とてもとてもわかりやすいんです
で はっきりしているんです
決して悪いことをしたら良い結果は出るはずがないんです
悪いという行為には必ずしも悪い結果
もう変えないんです どう頑張ってももう決まってるんです
しかし 私たちは悪いことをしたっても
うまくいく時もありますよと
いい加減なことを言う
それはもう因果の流れはわからないんだからなんです
余計につなげるんですよ
そんな科学はないんだからね
例えば 人が悪いことをしたならば
それには確実に決まってる悪い結果があるんです
その前に その人はいい結果も得るかもしれませんよ
得たいい結果は別なところでやった良い行為の結果なんですよ
それにつなげちゃうんで
変なつなげ方なんです
だからこの結果 行為と結果っていうのは
まあ間が考えちゃうと
行為をして一年で結果出る
行為をして半年で結果出るとかね
という場合は 人が悪いことをしたならば
そちらの結果が一年で出ると
で そこら辺でその人は何かいいことをしたならばしたんですけど
そちらの結果は半年で出る場合は
悪いことをしたことを見て
じっと見てると この人なかなかうまくいってるんではないかとこちらで考えるんです
これはこちらの勘違いなんですよ
行為に結果は決まってます
因果法則がわからないんだから
我々はそうやって誤解する
なんだかんだもいい加減で好き勝手につなげるんじゃないんです
なんだかんだいい加減につなげるんだったら
北海道に住んでる田中さんが今日もう畑仕事やってないんだから
こちら辺で雨が降ってないんだよと
って言ってもいいんですよ
すごいしっかりした言葉なんです
別に関係なくてもいいんだから
それは因果法則にはなりませんし
なんだかんだもつなげるんじゃないんです
世間ではもうなんだかんだもつなげる
だからもう世の中で悪いことをしなきゃうまくいかないんだぞとかね
嘘をつかなかったら成功しませんよとかね
で 平気で言う しかし 嘘をついて金儲けたら法律で罰を与えるとはっきり決まってるんですけど
悪いのは決まってますけど
法律でバレなくたっても
この商売関係の中で こういう嘘をついているんだとわかったらね
相手がそれで商売は断ち切るんだから
うまくいくはずがないんです
なのに人間のね そういういい加減なことを今
だからこの因果法則っていうのはなんとか理解してを見れば
ああ これにはこの結果
これにはこの結果っていうのは決まってるんだから
まあそんなに判断は難しくはないんです
もう一つ問題は 人々はこの判断するときは
あの過去にあった出来事を参考にする
それで それは判定基準にしようとすると
前にもこうして問題がなかったとかね
という言い訳にも役に立つし
そうやってこの前例を見るということがあるんですね
前例を見て判断すると役に立つ場合も立たない場合もあります
しかし 一番大きな問題っていうのは
判断には時間がかかる
いろいろ前例を調べなくちゃいけないんだから
仏教では どう見ていますかね
その場合は これ 法律ではいいんですよ
どうせ裁判には人のお金ですから
かかっているのは人の税金だからね
痛くも痒くもないし だから １ヶ月でも２ヶ月でも３ヶ月でも時間延ばして
ゆっくり前例を勉強して判断を下すと
それは法律でいいんだけど
生きてる上ではね そんなのんびりできませんだから
すぐ判断しなくちゃいけない
それで前例を考えたりすると
例えば子供はもう何て言いますか
万引きして捕まれたところで
いろんな方法を調べたりして
もう他のケースもありますから
万引きしたケースっていうのは
結構子供たちはそれ一つ一つ調べてみて
あなたどうしますか？あなたどうしますか
あなたどうしますか？と
この場合はとかね 調べてきて警察署に行くと
どういうことで そのそうなってくると何ヶ月かもかかるでしょうに
それは成り立たないんですよ
捕まれたと連絡来た途端
すぐ飛んでいかなくちゃいけないんだから
だから前例を調べる余裕はないんです
ということは調べなくてもいいんじゃないんですかね
前例なんかは で だと断決もできない
この調べるべき前例っていうのは正しいものだったら
一般方程式として世の中にいつでも頭にあることなんですよ
例えば悪いことをするな
嘘をつくなよというのはそういう前例なんですよ
人のものを盗むなよとかね
あまりいたずらするなよと
そういうの長い間のいろんな経験があって
もう常に世の中で生きてる前例なんです
ですから 具体例なんか要りません
だから前例は調べますけど
瞬時に頭にあるはずなんです
それ以外に何かどこがテキストなんか調べたりしちゃうと
これではちょっと合わないんですよ
例えば 年前の子供の万引きと今日の子供の万引きっていうのは同じじゃないんです
なんでやったんですか？っていうこと
同じじゃないんです しかし
同じなのは人のものを盗ったという
たったそれだけ なぜやったかということ
これはそれぞれケースバイケースで違う
だから年前の前例は今の問題の解決にはなりません
まだいろいろ難しいことばっかりなんですけどね
で 一つの判断は他の判断決断と矛盾しないかと
これは我々よくやりますね
ある時は何か決断したところで
また別なところになると
これは矛盾すると こともないわけでもないんです
大体は正しい判決 決断というのは矛盾はしないんです
一人の子供に早く寝なさいと言ったら
もう一人の子供 では私もということになっちゃう
あなたは違いますよと
あなたは勉強しなさいということはもある
それでお母さん矛盾ではないかと行っても
それは矛盾ではないんです
一人の子供に対しては
それは早く寝る必要があって
もう一人の子供はやっぱり寝るんじゃなくて勉強した方がいいという判断だから
まあそういうちょっとそれは一貫しています
矛盾ではありません 矛盾する判断するのは大体政治家なんですね
まあ恥があると政治になれませんだから
ですから 堂々ともう十分喋っていると
前に言ったことには全く違うんですよ
もう九分で喋っていることは
見事にねじ曲がってねじ曲がって話を持っていく
でも一貫しています いかに民衆を騙すかという
自分の方に回すかというね
そこら辺で一貫して矛盾だらけして喋るんですけどね
まあこれは分かった方がいい
役には立ちますけどね
で また残りのことっていうのは
すぐに大事なことがあって
選択 決定 決断 判定というと言ったことが求められた時
簡単にシンプルにこれが正解だという答えがね
出てくればいいのですが
実際はあれこれと迷い
悩むことが多いようです
すぐこれが答え正解というふうに言えればありがたいんですけど
やっぱり迷っちゃうんだと
単純にこれだと決定できたとしても
その決定が原因で後からトラブルが起きてくる時もまた多いです
さらに その決断に対して反対
異論 批判などが起こることもある
結局 がんじがらめのどうでもいいような小さなことまで
優柔不断に悩み迷って
多くの時間を浪費したり
トラブルで心身ともに疲労しますということで
よく迷ったりするんですね
これでいいのか これでいいのかっていうね
判断した後で大丈夫で
迷わなくてもね 判断してからは結果は出ますからね
良かろう悪かろう関係ないんです
判断したらもうすぐ結果が出ます
これは避けられません
自分で石を上に空に投げたら
それで十分です 迷わなくても
その石が落ちるんですよ
あるいは自分が人の家の窓ガラスを目掛けて石をぴったしストライク
ならばストライクではストライクですかね
で ストライクだといっても
で まあ後で悩むなこといいんですよ
もう結果は決まってるんです
一旦正確に投げたら もうそれでもう結果が決まっている
だから判断は正しいかどうか間違ってようか
どうにもならない もう一旦してしまえば
因果法則によって決まっている結果が確実に出てくる
女性の方々はすぐもう口を
そのとかとかね 目を閉じたりしますね
あれで変えるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
結果は あ いけないとかね
もう終わってますけど
だからこの悩むことっていうのは無意味ですよ
明らかに たとえ診断が間違っても
今更悩んでどうしますかね
今は問題は悩む暇がないでしょうに
起きた出来事を良くなかったら
その処理はどうするかという
もう大変な問題あるでしょうに
だからそういう決断なんかには悩む必要もないんです
一応そこら辺なんですよ
じゃあでは私の話に入ります
決断できない理由ということがありまして
これはまず環境の問題なんですね
結果に対する責任ということがあるんですね
判断はしても決断してもいいんだけど
責任という問題があります
だから我々は責任考えちゃいますから
もうなんかもう怖いんですよ
判断するのは 判断した人が責任あるでしょうに
だからこれが結構足を引っ張っちゃうんですよ
責任感は これに答えはないんですよ
責任あります 判断しちゃったら
そこで環境にもっとひどいことがあるんですよ
成功したら皆のおかげになっちゃうんです
みんな持っていくんですよ
せっかく判断した人は
もうあっち行けという感じになっちゃうんです
会社なんかでよくあるんですよ
いろいろ計画立てて 新しい何か開発したりとかするのは
もうコソコソコソコソとそれなりの社員たちがやってますけど
これすごくうまくになってきたら
まあ課長やら社長やら
まあすごく威張っても賞をもらったり
偉くもうテレビなんかに出て
それについて喋ったりとか
何もわからないのに そうやって他人が持っていくんですね
で 失敗したら自分の責任
と同じところでも 例えば一人の社員が何か開発して
もう億単位で儲かるヒット商品になったりする
それで次の品物を作ったところで
それも会社はかなりお金がかかりますから
全然売れなかったりすると
本人が責任持たなくちゃいけないんですね
成功した場合はもう会社の社長のもので
そうなっちゃうと もうやりきれないんですよ
人間っていうのは個人的には
ですから 成功すると奪われる
失敗すると見放されるということは
もう世の中にあります
だからみんな判断するのはできるだけ後回しにしたがるんですよ
だから気持ちはみんな同じですからね
そういうことになります
それはこの環境ということで
そういうわけで 誰でも出す結論は優柔不断は身の安全ということなんです
だから ほとんどの人々を見たら優柔不断ですよ
何もはっきり決めないんです
これはそういう環境が作る結果なんです
それで人を怒鳴っても
あんたなんで優柔不断でしょうかと
たら あなた方はそういうふうに私を作った
構成したのではないかと
言い返しがないんですよ
これは社会の影響で優柔不断になったりはします
その場合でも 仏教は個人主義で因果法則だから
まあ決めるのは本人なんですが
もうやりきれないんだと
こんなことではもうもう嫌やということで
みんな優柔不断になることに決めちゃうんですね
この方が安全だと はい
それからこの精神的な問題も 2番目に考えられますね
判断を迫られると もうすぐ迷っちゃうんですね
え？何？という感じで
こんなことでまだもうこれ
へー 私？という無責任感
これすごく情けないんですよ
その人に判断しなさいと言っているのは
その人に責任があるでしょうし
それでよくもこの無責任感で来てるんですよ
いわゆる大人になってないんですね
精神的には いつでも哺乳瓶で
あの 何て言いますか このバトルフィットエゴと言うんですけどね
もう育ててくれると思ってるんです
だから判断する時になった瞬間で
これは大人はもうもうすごくそういうことやりますよ
え？私？っていう感じで
すごい気持ち悪いんですよ
その状態も だから精神的には大人になってない
独立していない それが 2番目の原因なんですね
それで状況に目が覚めてない
永遠眠気 これ永遠眠気だと覚えておいた方がね
あまりにも気持ち悪くてやらないと思いますよ
誰を見ても本当に永久永遠眠気なんですよ
何回言わなかったらもう理解してくれない
同じ言葉はもう同じことをだいたい 20回ぐらい言わなくちゃいけない
で これで私と人間関係はいつでもトラブルなんですね
私は一回言われたら もう全部もうもう多重構想で理解するんです
で  2回目言うと もう気持ち悪くてうるさくて
これは我慢できますけど
これ 10回まで言うんだから
で 私はそれイライラしたっても
相手に対して見ると やっぱりこの 10回言わなきゃ
もうあ 何か言ったの？ってやっと目が覚めてくるんですよ
こんな永遠 永遠何民と言うんですか？永遠安眠してね
生きていられるはずがないんですよ
人生っていうのは戦場だから
これは一つの このまあ
精神的な問題なんですね
例えば授業したってもわからなかったとかね
これ寝ているんだからでしょうに
で いろんなところで会議には参加しましたけど
もうなんだかわからないんだとかね
あるいはみんなむちゃくちゃで
何言ってる ったり切ってる本人もわからないんだから
何か私はわかりますよというのは
それは正しいんですけど
ではなくて 自分が寝ていて
ずっと これは冗談じゃないんだよ
お釈迦様ははっきりとみんな寝ているんだよと
スッタンガーマン魔法マッチュアジャガチっていうあの芸
一部もう法華経にもありますからね
みんなこの寝ているんだから
もうみんなもう不幸になるんだと
もう何かという例えでいうのは
寝ている村は洪水で流されるようにと
突然雨が降って洪水になっちゃうと
これはインドの環境で言ってることで
山にインドっていうのはものすごい大きいんだから
もう雨が降ったかないかわからないんですよ
こちらは乾季かもしれませんよ
上の方でものすごく豪雨になる
と いきなり山がもう山ではなくて
この川が暴流で暴走してくるんです
それでこっちはすごく平気で
もう雨も降らないし このはこの頃はもう畑仕事もできないんだとか
グーグーと寝ている間に知らないうちに流されちゃうんです
そんな感じで 人間っていうのはもうもう四王にやられているんだと
寝ているんだから だからこれは仏教でははっきりとお釈迦様が言っている言葉で
まあ私たちはいつでも永遠に眠れているんだから
まあなかなか判断なんかできるわけじゃないと
それから間違ったらかっこ悪いという気持ちもあるんですね
判断迫られる時 やっぱり間違ったらこれはやっぱりかっこ悪いんだと
これはやっぱり見栄ですね
虚栄心ということなんですね
それから間違ったら 間違ったら恥というふうに思ったりする
これはまあ高慢であって
こういうことで判断しないことになる
まあ答えとして言えばね
この間違ったらかっこ悪いというのは
見栄なんかあるんだったら正しい判断すればいいでしょうし
もともと正しい判断できない人間だから
正しい判断できない人はかっこ悪いという権利さえもないんですよ
それから間違ったら怖いということもありますね
これはまあ精神的にはね
すごく弱いということで
ああ怖いとできないんだと
やべえと と思っちゃうと判断できるわけじゃないんです
で 批判に対応できない
批判には耐えられないですよ
対応というよりもね で
まあ批判というのは世の中で普通にあることで
これはない世界っていうのはない
まずそれはない ないと困りますよ
人間にはすべてわかるわけじゃないんだから
一人一人人間には一部しか見えませんよ
だから他の人にまた一部一部見えますから
そちらそちらあちらからいろんな意見があった方がいいんですね
それで自分が自分に見えるところで判断したら
相手の意見というのは批判になるんですよ
自然に それはもうないとすごく危ないし
でも気が弱い人々なんかは
この批判にはもう対応できないんですね
耐えられない これではもううまくいかない
ちゃんと対応しなきゃいけないんで
ああ そうですか と ではこういうことというふうにね
ということになります
それはこの精神的な状況で
だいたいそんなもんだとは思います
そういうことで判断できないんです
はい で それからこの 3番目
この何でしたっけね これ
日本語で言えば 我々の育ち方というか
オリエンテーションなんですね
我々は言われるままに生きてきたんですよ
だから自立してないんです
一人で何もできない いい子でいたんだけど
だから何もできない ただの飼い犬
飼い犬なんですね これ
オリエンテーションも社会の問題で
独立した人間育てるんじゃなくて
ものすごくいい飼い犬たちを作る
お手と言ったら手を出してくれる
次にマニュアルに従えば十分
これは現代病ですね マニュアルに従えば十分だと思っているんです
判断する必要ないんです
あのマクドナルドやらそういうファストフードの店で
台所というなんていいますか
裏見るとちゃんと絵で描いてるんです
ハンバーグの組み立て方とかね
誰にでもできるようにと
すぐその日でバイトに入った若者にも
しっかりと基準に沿って仕事はできます
なんて言いますか ジャガイモを油で揚げるんだったら
フライドポテトするならば
温度は自動で決まってあって
何分かと全部決まって
ストップウォッチまであるんです
そこでサーッともうジャガイモを投げちゃって
もう時計あれを押して
他の仕事に それでパッともうその時間に揚げれば
ちょうどもう全国同じ基準で揚げられています
それですごいというわけでもないんですよ
その子は自分のアパートに帰ってできるかというと
できないでしょうに 店で堂々ともうハンバーグ作ってフライドポテト一緒に売ってるのに
これはマニュアル通りにやってるんだからなんです
で その場合はいいかもしれませんだけど
人生は何でもマニュアル通りにやろうと思っちゃうと
もう判断できるわけじゃない
それからまた我々は余計なことに手を焼きたくないというね
という気持ちもあるんですね
そういうふうに我々は育てられてますから
本当に余計なことに手を出してはいけないんですよ
でも 判断するときは自分で判断しなくちゃいけないんです
それにまでその考え方を持っていくんです
それでおもしろいことは
自分で判断する場合は
同じ余計なことに手を焼きたくないと思うんだけど
他のことだったら一応口も手も足も出したりする
関係ないことに そういう生き方やってます
いわゆるあの手を出すといけないことには手を出す
口を出しいてはいけないところには口も出す
で 自分で責任を持って判断しなくちゃいけない時は
もうすぐもう手を引いたりしますね
次に 次の人間のやり方だな
一緒に一緒なら怖くないという
よく社会で見られるでしょうね
一緒ならもう何でもするんですけど
一人なら何もできない
一緒ならすごく凶暴で堂々と
これは世間によくあることなんですよ
日本で赤信号をみんなで渡れば怖くない
まあ一人で渡っても怖くはないんですけど
だって私がいるところで信号は赤か青か全然一度も見ないんだから
まあ一応まあ日本でそういうことわざになっているし
やっぱり日本の社会の若い若者の間でも
子供の間でもよくあるんですよ
特に子供っていうのは
ちっちゃな子供たちはいつでもグループでいるとものすごく凶暴ですよ
一人一人で学校から帰ったりする場合は
何のことなく ごく普通の子供で可愛いんですよ
けど これがもう五 六人グループ組んじゃうと
まあ大人が逃げた方がいいんじゃないかなと思う
凶暴になります そういうことで
もう一緒なら怖くないという態度っていうのは
自分が持つべき判断能力を壊しちゃうんですよ
そこで判断してほしくない場合は
世界で必ずこの手段を使いますよ
テレビでいろいろ国々のことを見てください
大勢集めて プラカード持って
いろんなことをやってるでしょうに
もう全然怖くないね その時は
で この独裁者やらね イスラムの過激派やらね
もう誰でも まあそういうイギリスでもどこでも
戦争過激賛成派でも 戦争は反対派でも
どちらでも 一緒なら怖くないということで動こうとしているんですよ
それでまんまと一般人を騙されて
いろんなことをやらされるんですよ
それはすべて判断ミスけど
個人ではもう言われるままやっちゃう
例えば この平和運動をやっているこのグリーンピース運動をやっている人々でも
結局はグループでやっていることはまるっきり平和的なことじゃないんです
警察と喧嘩するわ 火炎瓶投げるわ
いろんなことをしてとんでもないことをするんです
それって平和運動ですか？と
大変怖いんですよ だからまあそうやってこのするがすこい人々は
この人間には判断できないんだと
もうただの生き物やと
この人々は でもまあ犬としてはちゃんと育てられてますから
はい 右と言ったら右見えるし
はい左と言ったら左の方は見るし
はい お手と言ったら手を出してくれるし
そういうぐらいの教育がありますから
うまく使うんです ではみんなで一致団結して反対しようではないかとかね
それでみんなはいはいと言って手を挙げて
歓声を上げて グループで行動する
これでどうなるかというと
一人一人で自分で判断する能力がきれいさっぱりなくなってしまうんです
だからこれもこのオリエンテーションの問題で
そういうオリエンテーションあるんだから
私たちに判断できないんです
次の元はこの漫画主義と
私はもういい加減に書いたんですけど
漫画主義者ですね みんな
という意味はまた書いたんです
漫画主義って何なのかと
自分で考えて分析して理解するのではなく
提供される情報をそのまま鵜呑みにする
テレビやら新聞やら雑誌やら
もうもう言われること
あ そうですか それで終わり
全然その理解しようとはしないし
何言ってるかともしないし
だから我々は一方 情報というのは流されるまんまだから
情報はどういうことか調べることはできないんだけど
人間っていうのはもともとアホだから
いくらニュースで流しても矛盾があるんですよ
並べているところで事実からくりしているんだから
なんのことなく見えますよ
あ なるほど こういうことですかねと
だからあんたこう言ってるんだよと
そんなに研究する必要ないんですよ
ただ その人の話を聞いただけでも裏が見えてくるんです
しかし この漫画主義の世界では
これは全然できない だって漫画っていうのはどういうものかというと
全部絵でキャプションで全部書いてるでしょうに
痛いということは もう顔も痛い顔をして
いてと文字でも書いて
その上周りいろんな線やら
いろんなものも星やらいろんないっぱい書いてるんだから
もう考える必要ないんです
だからそこでも我々は自分の判断力がなくなっちゃいますね
それからこれ一番ややこしいんですよ
この中途半端な知識 あれも読んで
これも読んで あれも聞いて
これも聞いてとか みんななんかこのヤギみたいな
もうヤギって何食べるかわかる
紙も食べるし もう服も食べるんですよ
もうビニールシートみたいな
それも食べるんですよ
葉っぱも食べるわ もうもう毒になる葉っぱであろうとか
それも食べるわ 葉っぱがなかったら枝の皮も食べる
そこら辺で紙 もう普通の紙なんか落ちてるんだったら
これも全然全く平気で食べる
で ビニール袋とか何かあったらこれも食っちゃうという
そういうふうな考え方で
これなんでかんでもまあ読んだり聞いたりはするんだけど
別にどちらの専門家でもないんです
それでよく何でも知ってるんだぞと
私たちはあの人よく本読んでるんだから
いろんなとこ いろんなところ調べているんだから
世界中いろんなところに行ってるんだからとかね
まんまと騙される 私も騙そうと何人かチャレンジしましたから
日本でね 私はインドに行ってきたんだよと
私は何のこと？どれぐらいいたの？で
インドで 2 週間も歩き回ったんだからといって
もう 3000年  4000年の歴史のあるあの複雑の文化で何がわかるんですかね
それでどうせ外国人に喋るところだから
ろくなインド人じゃないし
騙されるの決まってるし
人を騙すってことはインド文化の一緒な一つなんですよ
決してこれはもう悪いと向こう見てないんです
私も別に悪いと見てないんです
インド人と喋ると まあこいつのはどうせ騙されるのは当たり前だから
まあこちらは騙されないように
こちらの勝負やと そこで騙されないのはこちら勝ったならば
向こうは必ず褒めてもくれるんですよ
もうさすがですよと そこでもう 1000円の品物はもう 4000円で自分が買って
後で儲けてあなたが悪いんだよと平気で言うんです ITIS
yourfault ユー言われたんだから
一回ユーディサイドプライスと
私はすぐすぐ日本的になっちゃって
値段決めるのは向こうではないかという
失敗しましたなと そこである人が 150ドルだと決めた品物がいらんと
いや じゃあ 140入りませんと
じゃあもうもうもう全然私に入りませんよと
あっち行けと言ったら
もうこれ以上はだから下げる必要ないんだよ
買わないんだから これ以上はどうしても
だからジャストノーニードトゥローダウンザプライス
ビコーズイドントノウトゥバイと言ったんです
で また来るんですね では中途でいりませんね
それで向こうはもう全部もうネタが切れちゃって
ではあんたはいくらだったら買いますか？と
で 私はこれはまあ 60 50ドルにしたっても
ね 私には何の価値もないんだと
随分下げちゃったんですね
言ったら あ その値段では売れません
だってそうでしょ だからまあ商売も相談終わりと
だからザビジネスオールと言ったんです
でも本人はそれでも負けたわ
負けたくはないんです
私は入れましたら 最後に何でしたっけ？それはまあ
では何ドルだったらまた聞くんですね
買ってくれますか？まあいりません
まあそこまで言うならば
２０ドルだったらあげますよと
そしたらもう断ってもう買える段階になったら
まあしょうがない じゃあまあ 20ドルくださいと
そしたら 158ぐらいのものっていうのを 20ドルで買ったんだから
全部こちらの勝ちなんです
しかし 私はその人は損させたというと
そうじゃないんですよ
結局 あれはまあまあ 2 3 ドルぐらいのものですよ
結局は インドの値段知ってますから
これはもう人は手で作りますけど
これはもうどれぐらいと人件費やらも何もないしね
それを知ってます 知ってるし
だからこの人を騙しているとインド人は思ってないんです
そういうことで  1週間ぐらいね
日本 インドでちょっと回ってきてね
私にあれやこれやと言っても
だからこの知りすぎですよ
知りすぎっていうのは
知らなすぎ 知らなすぎということになるんです
だから半端な知識よりは知らない方が便利ですよ
そうすると正直で教えてもらうんだからね
あんたもうダメよ わからない
じゃあこういう風にしなさいよと誰かが教えてくれるんだから
私も日本のあちこち行く場合は
この半端な知識しかないんだから
結構迷子になっちゃうんですね
で 来た時は迷子にならなかったんですよ
ちゃんと人に聞くんです
今は聞かない 誰が聞くもんかと
言って間違うんです だからもう半端な知識よりは知らない方が安心ですよ
だから一番このオリエンテーションの問題で
これがものすごい大きい問題ですよ
判断を迫られる時は どうでしょう
あれでしょう 特に私はすごく痛い目で見ている
考えているんですよ 人々にちゃんと道を教えているのに
本人も瞑想をいろんなことをして
それなりに人生が明るく軽くなっていることを知っているのに
まだまだもう疑いをしてかかってくるんですね
あまりにもむちゃくちゃで
知りすぎということを見せようとする
あまりにもひどくなっちゃうと
私はやっぱりもう反論ではなくて
もう答え出すんですよ
出したところで 今まで知りすぎでしたけど
私はもうやっぱり何も知らなかったということで
あまりにも大恥をかけられて
それっきりでもう全部コミュニケーションがなくなっちゃうんです
それで私 私知ったことがないんだと
なんでそういうふうに抗議してくるんでしょうかと
だからこの何か読んだだけで
もう立ち上がってこない方がいいんですよ
はっきりとその分野でプロだったらいいんです
その時私はすぐ叫びます
時々お医者さんの方々も説法なんか聞きに来ます
来ます 私はそれ知らないんだから
時々医学のこととか何とかとか平気で言ったり
私はプロでもなんでもないんですよ
時々その人々はあまりにも変なことを言うと
実は私はこういうものなんですと
こうじゃなくて こういうことよと言った途端
ああ そうですかと すぐそこは勉強する
だからそれはまあ そういうふうなやり方だから
まあこれすごく問題になるんですよ
どんな社会でも どんな会社でも
国会ででも どこででも
まあ半端な知識で決断はできなくなる
こうではないか ああではないか
そうしたってもこうではないかとかね
こんな風になるはずがないんですよ
この役に立たない半端な知識だから
どんな知識でも半端だったら
もうもうもう役に立たないでしょうに
ということで はい それはこの 3番目です
またありますね それからこの心のあの構成というかね
前説明したのはオリエンテーションということでね
今はこの自分の内て内の内心的な
この構想の問題 妄想ばかりしている
それによってということで
次ひとつですよ 我々はこの現実離れで
ガチャガチャガチャガチャあり得もしないものを考えているんですよ
それによって現実離れになってしまうんですよ
あまりにも妄想ばっかりしていると
これで判断できるわけないでしょうに
それも前に説明したこの永遠眠気状態なんです
妄想していると もう永遠眠気状態なんですね
何か人がいて あ あれ何？というふうな状態になっちゃうんです １０
回も言わない限りは あの妄想の流れは止まってくれないんです
それで現実離れになる
それで精神的なエネルギーは浪費する
物事を理解するためには結構エネルギーが必要ですよ
例えば ものすごく頭を使う人々は
全然運動しなくても結構食べたりはしますよ
食べても太らないんです
もう全部エネルギー使ってるんだから
だから妄想っていうのはかなりエネルギーは使います
そういうことだから もう判断というのはもうあの相撲みたいなものなんですよ
相撲では稽古は長い時間やりますけど
実際の勝負は１分以内で終わっちゃいますから
たった１分の勝負のためにどれほど苦労するかと
だからもう判断する人生というのは
我々もみんな力士 相撲の力士なんですよ
判断する場合は もう全部エネルギーを縛ってパッと判断しなくちゃいけないんです
ですから このエネルギーは浪費しちゃうとできるわけじゃないんですね
感情でダラダラ喋るが
理性を要求されると頭がパニック
よく喋る人々いるでしょうに
これはどう？まあなんとかしなくちゃいけないんだけど
言ったら 喋るは喋るは喋るわ
いろいろ情報 あれこれとかね
それは単なる感情で もうダラダラダラダラ
もうもう犬が吠えているような感じなんです
なんで吠えてるか犬もわからないし
それで理性に理性を要求すると
頭がパニックになっちゃう
よく喋れなくなります
これ 私はよく使う手段で
人が喋るは喋るは切りがないと
私はそれで何言いたいの？いずれそれ出す
それであなた何言いたいの？と
途端 カチーンと止まるんです
もう喋れなくなっちゃうんです
それで私はではまたということにできます
こういうことだから いわゆる我々心の中でぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ夢物語作ってストーリー作って苦労しているんだから
判断なんかはできるわけじゃないんですよ
そういうふうな このいろんなことで
我々には判断できない状態
状況っていうのはできているんです
それは一応４つに分けては説明しました
はい 次に行きます で これからもう返事出します
答えがないとね 判断ミスの４つの原因があります
我々はなんで間違っている判断するのかということでね １
番目はパーリ語でチャンダというんです
これは何回何回もこの
紹介はしました チャンダっていうのはこのパーソナルフェイバープレファレンスということなんです
で 日本語には意欲なんですね
この場合は何かをやり遂げたいという意欲ではありません
個人の好みです 愛情ですね
まあ分かりやすい あれがやりたい
好きですよとかいう気持ちなんです
これで判断ミスをするんです
あのよくあることは この
この日本語は分かりません
意味はね この英語ではフェイバリティズムという言葉がありまして
辞書では依怙贔屓という言葉なんですけど
あるのです ありますか
それからまあ このネポティズムという言葉もあります
これはまあ縁故採用というふうな意味なんですけど
これもチャンダで起こるんですね
で そういうそこら辺でどういうことかとわかるんです
例えば もう人を採用しなくちゃいけない時は
まあ成績だったら やっぱりこの人やってことになっちゃうんです
もっと資格ある人がいるかもしれませんだけどね
やっぱりそれは見えなくなっちゃうんですね
また 日本では美人は得するという言葉がありますね
あれはこれですよ 何かもう美人だったら
何か悪いことをしたっても
もうすぐ許してくれるんですね
なんとかそれはあまり問題にはしない
悪いことだったら 誰がしたって悪いんですけど
相手が美人だったら もうすごい何のことにもならないんですね
そういうふうな この人間の心には
可愛いだったら 美人だったら好きだったら
判断するときはそちらに傾いちゃうんですね
気持ちは 傾いてした判断だから
明らかに間違った判断なんです
政治家も失敗するのはそういうわけなんです
で 韓国でだけ誰かの大統領がやられちゃったでしょうね
あの大統領でもなくなっちゃって
裁判にもかけられちゃって
で 息子がいろいろなことをやったということで
本人は何もやってないんですけど
でも大統領の権力やらいろいろ影響ありますから
息子はいろんなことに手を出しちゃったりして
大統領は自分の息子だからね
まあ放っておくんですね
可愛いんだからね いくらなんでも頑張ってるんだと
と思ったところで 国を管理している大統領がね
そこら辺でもう失敗を犯しちゃう
それでそうなってしまったんですね
同じことマレーシアでも起きたんですけどね
マハティールという総理がいて
彼の息子やらあらゆることをして
不正も不正いいところでひどいことをやっちゃうんですね
それが人々はこれは良くないんだっていうことで反対をしたんですね
そうしたらマハティールがわざわざと罪を作って
その人々はみんな潰して刑務所に入れちゃったんです
言って 我が子を助け上げたんです
で 今も日本でも NHK で素晴らしい総理大臣だとか番組もあったんですね
私は無理もないと 評価の基準知ってますから
こちらの悪人でなきゃ褒めてくれないという
ガイアで政治やったんだからね
完全悪っていうことではないんですけど
まあかなりやっていることはやってます
でも韓国ではそこはできなかったんです
そういうふうな この我々は
この好みで 好きで 感情で
愛情で まあ美人が得するという論理で生きているんです
だから正しい判断をしたければ
これは絶対 いくら可愛く見えても
データだけ見るしかないんです
で これは 1番目 覚えた方がこれは覚えた方がいいんで
これはものすごい大変なことで
これは 4つしかないんですよ
だから正しい判断するためには
この 4つを覚えればいいんです
これはブッダの言葉そのものなんです
これが判断を間違うことで
この 4つ避ければ もう何のこともなく判断できます
ですから 厳密に覚えておいた方がいいんです
ということで 覚える 覚えられる前に 2番目に行きます
で  2番目は動作ということ
これはパーソナルヘイトリベンジということで
リタリアーションということで
怒りですね 怒りで仕返し
気持ちに支配されていると
例えば会社にしたっても
ある社員のことは何か気に入らん
わけもわからないんだけど
まあまあ気に入らんと
そういう気に入らん気持ちあると
その社員に関わるどんな判断にしたっても
正しい判断はできないんです
気に入らないということは先に出てくるんだから
だから個人的な怒りとかね
例えばどこかで課長と一緒に飲んでいた時は
ちょっと何か課長に対して失礼なことでもしたならば
これは覚えておいちゃうと
もう人生終わりなんですね
その人の だからいろいろなことを判断して
判断して その人を不幸にしようとするんですよ
そんなもんで正しい会社経営はできませんよ
怒りが出しちゃうと 親たちもやりますよ
何人か子供いると やっぱりこの気に入ってる子供っていうのはやっぱりいるんですよ
言う口では言うんだけど
自分が産んだ子供だからみんな同じだよと
それはこの一人のことには結構手を出したりするんだけど
もう他の子供は一応放っておいたりする
それでその子供不幸になったら
トラブル起こっちゃったら
まあどうせ母は手を出しますけど
そこまではもう本当に知らないんですね
何やってるかとも そこで同じ間違いしたところでは
自分のフェイバリットの子供には優しいし
あんまり気に入ってない子供には厳しいということになるんですよ
これはもう母さえも子供にやることだから
かなり危険なことなんです
社会ではやらないわけじゃないでしょうに
父親 母親さえも何人か子供があるとやってしまうんです
それは気に入らないところにはちょっと厳しいと
だからこれがすごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
そこでこの 状況判断ができない
これ まあちょっと英語で書いてるものは日本語に書いてない
あ 書いてます 一時的に期待する結果を得るかもしれませんが
やがて自己破壊を招くと
例えばこの仕返しするつもりで
じゃあこうしましょうと言ってやったら
確実に仕返しになるかもしれませんよ
相手が潰されるかもしれませんだけど
同時に自分も破壊されてしまいます
だから ただアメリカが勝ったんですよ
イラクで ただ 誰かを潰したい
自分たちのプライドのためにという
誰でもいいんだから やっぱり一番勝ちやすいところは
まあそちらイラクでしたから
当時はイランはまずいし
トルコもあんまりまずいしね
もうキューバは隣にあるんだけど
やっぱり手を出したらまずいしね
じゃあイラクにしましょうと
結構大人 イラク人が不戦でも
であっ ここはいいやと言って潰したんですけど
それでやっぱり長期的に見ると自分たちがすごく不幸になっていくんですよ
もう赤字ばっかしで 人は若い者はもう殺されるわ
もう切りがないんですね
どこまで不幸が長引くかわからないんですね
イラク人も 1週間ぐらい逃げ回ったらよかったのにね
だから 1週間  2週間ぐらい逃げ回って逃げ回っていて
今からもう何年こちら逃げ回らなくちゃいけないんですかね
アメリカ側が だからどう見たって負けてるんですよ
アメリカが空から爆弾を落とす場合は
イラク人は逃げて じゃあ 2週間ぐらい頑張ろうと食べなくても大丈夫だと
で それで勝ったぞと 戦争終わりましたよというふうな宣言して
外出て 外の世界に出たところで
毎日逃げなくちゃいけない状態なんですね
だから客観的に判断すると
もうとっくに負けてるんですよ
一番負けっていうのは
荷物畳んで帰ることもできないし
いることもできない状態なんです
これは最悪なんですよ
もうやめた 諦めた もうもう一人出て行けばいいのに
それもできないんですよ
だからこのだから判断するときは
怒りを絶対使ってはいけないんです
それは 2番目 で  3番目に行きます
映えというもの これはこの何でしたっけ？IF というかね
怖いということですね
これはパーソナルフィアー
あるいはウィークネスという
弱いんですね だから怖い
弱い人は怖いんです 怖い
怖さ感じる  脅威感を感じることですね
この場合は自分で判断するのではない
相手に責められた判断をする
自分でハンコ押してるんじゃないんです
押されてるんです ハンコ押せと
はい わかりましたと 押すだけ
脅迫されてるってことですね
うん はい だから脅威感は自分が感じるということで
こちらから言うんだからね
脅迫されて言ったら外側からでしょ
であんまり仏教ではね
内側から実践するんだから
ちゃんと様子ば読むというのは心の状況だからね
これであるんだから こういう風に
まあ何ていうか 脅威感は感じるんです
心になかったら なんでハンコ押さなくちゃいかんですかと
というふうに立ち上がれると
これ間違いないと やらんだと言えるでしょ
だから だから脅迫されるという言葉は使わないんです
原因は自分にあるんだと
具体的な例を言いましょうか
決してアメリカは日本を脅迫しているわけじゃないんです
こちらの弱みですよ 危険取ろうと言って自衛隊派遣に決めてるんです
じゃらんそうと言えばそれだけのことでしょうに
だって憲法作ったのはあなた方ではないかと
我々は平和国家ですごくプライド持ってますよと
人のプライド傷つくなよと言えばいいでしょ
言えるところが思い出すもしないでしょうに
そんなことは だから弱いんですよ
精神的に だからこの やっぱりうちの原因で間違ってる判断はします
そこでこの相手に怯えてですか
これ 読み方はする判断はね
自分の幸福にはなり難いんです
もうこれは当たり前ですよ
だから その理屈で日本の自衛隊派遣の問題も考えてください
これは相手に怯えてやっている判断ですよ
決して日本の利益に 国家の利益にはなりません
仏教からははっきりしています
日本の政府は何よりも先に国益を考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
日本に対する攻撃はアメリカに対する攻撃だと言ったのは
あの大統領だけど バカじゃないかと
あれぐらいのことで国の
...政策決めますかね
あまりにもこの酔っ払いの言葉でしょ
あんなのは だから この
これは私の個人的な意見ですから
皆様は別に自分の意見でよろしいですけど
で 私はあんなのは酔っ払いの戯言しか見えません
あんな話は もしアメリカはそれをはっきりした公の文書にしているならば
法律文書にしているならばしょうがないんです
どこにもそういうふうにしてないんです
酒飲みながら言った話なんです
二人で そんなこといっぱい言いますよ
英語っていうのはそういう言葉だから
マーベラスとかゴージャスとか
オーグレートとかね くだらんことに言うんで
それはただの言葉の使い方ですよ
マーベラスってグレートってワンダフルとかね
こういう風な このすごい極端な単語を使って
そういう人々は喜んでいるんです
別に あれは一つの楽しみなんです
あれ文化違うんだからね
もうしょうがないんです
えーと まあ大体そんなもんで
あのデシジョンオブディスタイプはオールモストロングアンドハードリービカムベネフィット
それは書いていますね
決して自分のためになる
だから この弱いという気持ちで
気持ちは捨てた方がいいんですよ
相手がいくら凶暴であろうとも
悪いは悪い いいものはいいというふうにはっきりしないと
だから この何と言いますか
真理をねじ曲げるよりは
死んでも格好はいいんですよ
ということで 4番目に行きます
最後に 最後は毛髪という無知ということなんですね
無知なので状況判断はできない
また間違いね 文章は ので
何かを決める 何か決める
それだけ 無知な人っていうのは
もうそういうものが早く言う前にも判断しているんです
もう何も状況判断 これだからこうなる
あれですね はいはいはいはい
わかりましたって もう決まってるんです
あまりにも判断がないんです
もうたまにでもうまくいくわけではありません
だからといって もともと無知だから皆様反論するかもしれませんが
それでも判断しないよりはましではないかと
まあよしとあしとわからず判断しないで
たまにでもあまりにもうまくいかないんです
そんな遊びじゃないんです
判断っていうのは だから
この俺 英語で言えばわかりやすいんですよ
イストピッドデシジョンサーオールウェイズイストピッド
もう当たり前のことなんです
まあ番目の文章はちょっと難しいんだから置いておいたってもいいんですけど
番目は覚えられますよ
イストピッドデシジョンサーオール
だからイストピッドって言うんですからね
だって皆様イストピッドという言葉ご存知でしょ？日本語でも使いますからね
その中でもこの無知な判断
あまりにも怖いんですよ
例えば あの縁故採用つぎでやっても
まあ気分じゃ気持ちだけはわかるでしょ
あの人はもうね 全く資格もないのに
もう選んだんで まあ自分の息子だからって
気持ちだけでもわかりますよ
批判はしても やっぱり親バカやとかね
これもできんですよ  4番目の場合は本当に怖いんです
で 真偽の人の判断も怖いが予測できます
それから怒りでやっちゃうと判断すると怖いんでしょうね
例えばブッシュ大統領がもう誰かわからないんだけど
怒って何かするそうと決めて
イラクを敵に回しちゃったっていうこと
そうすると大体わかります
それからどうなるかということは
結果は だから逃げることでもできます
でも 無知の場合はね 予測さえできません
何判断するかわからないですよ
無知な人は 例えば あの人はえらく私に対して腹が立ってるんだから
これ頼んでもこうなるでしょうとわかってますよ
あるいは あ あの人はこの人のことをえらい気に入ってるんだから
この人を出して頼めばうまくいくでしょうとわかるんですよ
判断２つ間違ってますけどね
でも結果は予測できます
無知の場合はもうできない
だからとても怖いんです
これで 4つは終わります
一旦休憩いたしまして
次は説明をします はい
それでは それでは始まります
それからまあまあまあ
4つは絶対やめれば それから自動的に正しい判断できます
それから正しい決断のためにいろいろペパレーションというか
心構えですね あります
で 妄想を控えること 止めること
いわゆる現実と関係ない
ただ頭の中で考える ぐちゃぐちゃっていうことは全くやめることなんです
いつでもすごく具体的に物事を考えればいいんですよ
はっきりといい悪いは決めるわ
好き嫌いは決めるわ あんまりぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ頭の中で考えることは全くやめた方がいいんですよ
だから控えるとか言っても
やめることっていうのは難しいんだからね
論理性 理性を喜ぶ だから妄想する人々っていうのは
いろんな夢を見ながら
それでも暗い生き方をしているんですよ
お金があればいいなとか
あるいはこれもっと美人になればいいなとかね
ものすごい暗いんですよ
そんな暗い思考ではなくて
論理的なことを こうだからこうなったんですね
なんでこれはこうならないんでしょうかとかね
なんで地球は自転してるんでしょうかねとかね
それでもいいんですよ
これが止まったらどうなるんでしょうかとか
なぜならば妄想かもしれませんだけど
論理的で それでも 例えばもう地球の自転が 1時間止まったらどうなるんでしょうかと
科学的に計算できるでしょうに
太陽が当たっている方ではどれぐらい激しく光が当たるか
どれぐらい熱が地球に降り注ぐかとかね
いくらでもくだらん妄想なんですけど
それでも論理的なんですよ
だからそこまでやりたければそういうことをやってほしい
だからとにかく理性を喜ぶ
次に他人がするべき判断を自分でもシミュレーションしてみる
これも結構いい遊びなんですよ
まあ皆様はもうあまり興味ないんだと思いますけど
例えば国会のいろんなことをもう放送するでしょ
その場で 私は見ますけど
で 私はシミュレーションしますよ
あの質問にこういう風に答えているんだけど
うまくいってないなとかね
その場合はこう答えればよかったんではないかとかね
小泉さんはこういう風に言った方がよかったのに
なんだあの話は とかね
それで逆にこの人はこうやって疑問質問を出すんじゃなくて
こういう風にした方がよかったではないかとかね
全然私に関係ないんですよ
でも 世の中の人間の思考といろんな議論の構成を勉強するために
一つそこでシミュレーションしてみるんですよ
そういうことも大変必要なんで
正しい判断をするために心構え
はい で これ誤っていうのは間違ってるという感じでは漢字が入ってないんです
うん 誤判断の原因もシミュレーションしてみる
時々世の中でも あれ あの判断は間違ったということもあるでしょうし
それもシミュレーションする
その場合はどんなシミュレーションすればいいんですかね
あの決断が間違ったとガチャガチャ言うんじゃなくて
なぜ間違った決断に判断に至ったのかと
その人はどういうデータを考えたんでしょうかと
どんなデータをあえて無視したんでしょうかと
間違った判断に至った過程をシミュレーションしてみる
そういうふうにね 次にそれに落ち着いている
びっくりしたり舞い上がったり
それではなくて そこを落ち着いている
落ち着いていると すごく脳細胞をリラックスしているんですよ
だから結構いい判断はできます
自分の自慢のために決して判断しないこと
あの これがみんなやってます
だからみんなの判断間違ってますよ
決めたのは私でしょうと
私も時々言いますけど
あれはただふざけて冗談で言ってるんです
面白くないんだから 何か言ってふざけてやるぞと
それだけのことで 決して判断というのは自分の自慢のためにやるものじゃないんです
例えば 日本の総理大臣である小泉さんが
あの小泉がこれを決めたというふうに自慢のためにやろうとすると
確実に間違うんです ではなくて
判断というのは自分のものでも他人のものでもないんですよ
これは自然なものだから
国家として判断せなければいけない場合は
何々さんが決めるんじゃなくて
国に対してどんな判断でしょうかっていうことで
だから家の中での判断もそういうことなんです
晩ご飯の料理何にするかという判断も
私がこういうことを決めたんだからといって
そんなことはないんですよ
だから晩ご飯決める場合でも
もう食べる人々は決まっているんだから
その人々はみんな大変喜ぶ
健康にいいものは何なのかと判断するんであって
だから自分の自慢のためにっていうことはよく入り込むことで
それはもう避けた方がいい
はい で 知っていますか？決断の目的
次にこれ あれば心構え
これからはこの別なこと
この判断する時の基準なんです
心構えがあってから基準に行くんです
これはまあエヴァナソーでパーパスオブテーキングディシジョンという何か目的があって
何でしたっけ？判断決断するのです
で それは妄想にふけて感情に負けて
忘れる 我々は判断する場合は何か目的があるんですよ
何のための判断ですかと
ごちゃごちゃ考えてるんだから
それ忘れちゃいますね
それは決して忘れてはいけないんですね
何かをすれば良いという気持ちになる
それで あ 何かすればいいんじゃないかと平気で思ったりする
目の前 あるいは目の前の結果しか考えない
すぐ目の前の結果しか考えないということもある
で やってみなきゃわからないという無知にかけてみるということもしますね
これは無知に賭けるんですよ
やってみなきゃなんでわからないと言うんですか？因果法則わからない
バカが言うでしょうに
やったことには決まってる結果があるんだから
そういうことなんですね
まだわからないとこありますかね
だいたいまあまあダラダラと書いてるだけですけど
まあ一応そのポイントなんですね
ポイントを示す黒い点がありますけど
このフレームのおかげで見えないんです
だからこんな調子ではなくて
はっきり目的を明確に出してもらわないと
これだったら目的がなくてもいいってことだからね
明確に目的を出してみようということです
はい 続きます それで決断の目的
これやってみなきゃわからないというこの言葉が正しいことなのにやらない怠け者に対するしつけなんです
これ 場所を間違って使ってはいけないんです
やってみなきゃわからないけど
だからやりなさいというのは
この腰抜けの怠けにいうしつけの言葉なんですよ
言う人はわかってるはずなんです
やればいい結果になるんだよと
大体親が子供には言うんです
先生は生徒には言うんです
子供はやりたくないんだから
いろいろこんなもう あれやこれややってみなきゃわからないんでしょうと
やりなさいと言わなくちゃいけない
それはこの上の人がそうやってしつけで言う言葉なんです
これが見事に無知に欠けている世界に澄ま使っているんです
それで決断は賭けではダメですよ
そんな賭けじゃないんです
良い結果を得たいというのは目的です
これははっきりしているんです
良い結果出したいんです
幸せの結果出したいんです
これを忘れてはいけないんです
では次に行きます 良い結果とは
良い結果を判断する方法はこれから行くんですね
自分にとって好ましいのか ISIT
beneficial for oneself? という 1番目
2番目 他人にとって好ましいのかという ISIT
beneficial for beneficial to others ということ
3番目 自分にも他人にも好ましい結果になるのでしょうか ISIT
beneficial to both oneself and others という
日本語は覚えにくいんだから
英語で覚えてください
そちら 3つあります はい
次に行きます それで説明に行きます
前に言ったような この道徳の基準
これは本当は道徳の基準なんです
判断についても同じ基準を適用します
なぜなら 決断判断は行動するために行うものです
ただ決めただけで寝るんじゃないんだからね
決めたから行動するんだから
行動だったら道徳的なんですよ
善し悪しがあるんです
ですから ここは使います
そういうことで 最後はしようとする決断が悪いか良いかは行いやすい順番で考えていくんです
理解しやすい順番で考えていくんです
で この順番です 前に書いたのは
はい 次 で 次は 1番目 で
1 は自分にとって好ましい結果になるのかということですね
私にとっていいのかということで
これはある程度で理解しやすいでしょ
自分のことだから 誰でも何よりも先に自分の利益を考える
自分の利益になれば判断に飛び込みたくなるのです
しかし これでは偏見に決まっている
大体世間ではほとんどの人々は
自分の利益になるんだったらすぐ飛んでやろうと判断しようとする
あ これで儲かるぞと これが気をつけてほしい
これはこのおっかえで言ったんだから
商売の話っていうわけじゃないんですよ
家庭でお母さんが小さな子供に対する判断にしても同じことなんです
いつでも自分にとっていいことで決めちゃう
決めて子供を責めちゃうんです
自分の楽だけ考えて だからこれは人生全体的な問題なんです
それから次に行きます
これは 1番目の説明ですね
自分に利益があると思っても
それは利益ではなく損になることもある
例えば 自分の利益も自分の便利さだけ考えて
子供にあれこれやと言ったところで
やがてそれはもう大変なことになって変わってくる時もあります
例えば 自分がいろいろなことをやりたいんだから
子供はいろんな塾に行かせたり
あっちこっち入れたりして
もうできるだけ子供を忙しくしておく
これでうまくいってるんだと
でも 子供にも母親と仲良くする
接する時間がほとんどなくなっちゃって
家に寝るだけのために帰っちゃうでしょうね
やがてとんでもないことになるんですよ
だから自分ではいいと思っても
もしかすると悪いかもしれませんよ
それだったら この利益だと勘違いしているかないかも調べる
他人に聞いてみたり 相談してみたり
利益であろうとも したりする
利益であろうとも ただで得るものではないので
割に合うかないかも調べてほしい
それからそれだけですね
この条件さえ揃っていればOKです
判断はできます それは 1番目の条件なんです
それぐらいきめ細かく考えてほしい
では 次に行ってみましょうか
これ 2番目の条件 他人にとって良いかないか調べる
2番目は他人に対して
この判断は良いかないかと調べてみる
いい結果で出るかないかということは
それで他人といえば 2種類ですよ
1番目  1 は自分の周り
味方 仲間 親しい人 家族などですね
これ 1番目の他人です
2番目は相手です 相談などで見られるのですね
まあ関係ないんですけど
その相手なんですね だからこの他人というのは 2種類あります
これを覚えてください
他人には良い話だが 自分にとって損なら損なら大体アウトに決まっている
大体はね 例えばある会社と相談する
そこでこれうまくいったら
会社は儲かるんだけど
こちらは大変だと なんか儲かる見込みもないんだと言ったら
もうどうせアウトでしょうに
決めません その相談は契約は作りません
しかし 一の他人なら妥協もあります
例えば家族だったらね
家族は何か決めた もうみんな決めようとするんだけど
自分にとっては最悪なんですね
何のいいこともない でもまあせっかく家族にはもう利益あるんだから
まあいいんじゃないかっていうことで妥協するとこでもあります
その場合は自分が本当は損していていますけど
まあ 1番目の仲間だからね
いろいろ犠牲にならなくちゃいけない時もあります
でも  2番目だったらもうアウト
やらない 例えば 日本の国はどちらの国とは何かを契約を書く
条約を作る それで向こうにとっては最高いいんだけど
こちらにとっては悪いことしか何もないんだったら
すぐ取り消さなくちゃいけないんです
それやってますか？この国はと
わざわざと自分が損して他人だけ儲かる
調停なんか決めてもかっこいいと思ったら勘違いですよ
かっこいいわけじゃないんです
やっぱり他人が他人だったらね
どちらも利益ないとね
しかし 身内の場合は まあいくらか犠牲になったって
これはしょうがないんですよ
そちらにだけ妥協があるんです
はい 続きます また 2番目の続きなんですね
他人にだけではなく 自分にも利益がないという
ないといけないのです
この利益っていうのは
他人だけじゃなくて 自分にもあってほしいんです
ですから 自分だけに良いだったらダメなんですね
他人だけ良いんだったら
これもダメなんですよ
それから自分にはもう丸じゃなくて三角
わからない どうかなと
他人には丸か三角なんですね
それがということになります
いわゆる自分には他人にはだけいいんだったら
もうやっぱり結果も三角になります
それなぜ書いたかというと
この身内の他人の場合なんですね
これ この下から 2行目書いたのは
この身内の他人の場合は家族も他人ですよ
だから家族にはいいんだけどっていうところになってくると
まあやっぱり三角なんですね
答えは はい それで 3番目に行きます 3
番目  3番目 自分にも他人にも良いという判断
判断は普遍的に良いということになります
例えば 決めたところで判決したところで
結果は自分にもよろしいし
他人にもよろしい もう問題はありませんと
だったら堂々であるしかないんですよ
それは普遍的に良いということなんです
必ずしも人間するのはその判断なんですよ
だから仏教は三条件言ってますけど
1は不完全  2も不完全です
1合格して 2合格して 3まで合格しなくちゃいけないんです
3まで合格しちゃうと
もう文句はない はっきり決めた方がいいんです
堂々と 要するに これしか判断がないということです
こんなもんで簡単ですからね
早く終わりにしましょう
それでまた判断の良し悪し
主観的な判断はすべて間違い
これで私も判断してみせるんです
今まで曖昧で喋ったんですけど
で こうやって判断できます
主観的な判断 自分だけ考えてする判断はもうすべて間違い
偽善的な判断はすべて間違い
世のために 人のためにとか
いろいろいろんな被りを被って
主義のためにとかね そういう偽善的な判断もすべて間違い
感情の判断もすべて間違い
欲やら怒りやら そういうことにする判断もすべて間違い
一部に損する判断は巧みではない
いわゆる自分は得する
他人は損する あるいは自分は損するんですけど
自分は損するんですけど
他人は得すると言ったっても
あんまり巧みじゃない
だからかっこいいってわけでもないんですね
一部に損する判断も間違う場合は多い
その場合も大体判断は間違っています
大体はね 一部でも損すると
それも気をつけましょうということで
まあいいでしょう また続きます
善し悪しは自分とともに
皆の幸せは判断の基準なのです
これから全部判断できます
一方的に自分とともに皆の幸せということは
その基準で判断する場合は
もうこれは基準です 正しい判断のために
この基準に基づいた判断は正しいです
表面的に幸せのように見えなくても
真理に基づいた判断も正しいです
特例じゃありません 表面的には幸せとは見えないんですよ
でも正しいんです 例で言えば
仏教はね 欲を控えなさいよと
やりたいんだからとやるなよと言うと
うーんっと口になるでしょうに
酒なんかやめなさいというと
うーっと言っても楽しいなのにとかね
それで仲間とうまくいってるのにとか気持ちが出ますよ
でもあれは真理に基づいた判断だから
表面的に悪く見えても
これは正しい判断ですよ
真理に基づいた判断は悪果は出さない
いわゆる真理に基づいて表面的にはやりたくないんですよ
例えば嘘をつかないということとかね
本当は嘘をついた方が便利ですよ
不倫やらする人々にとっては
嘘がなければもうどうにもならんだからね
で 便利なんですけども
しかし 真理に基づいて本当のことをやるぞと思ったら
決して悪い結果は出てこない
確実に幸福な結果にはなります
だから常に まあお釈迦様おっしゃってる真理ですからね
世の中にあるのは  それに基づいて行動すればもう問題はないんですよ
あ そんなもんで まあそろそろ終わると思います
決断は意外に簡単 そこはうまくいけば
決断っていうのは思うほど難しくないんですよ
ぐよぐよする必要ないんですよ
悩みすら 前喋ったもの
一つも成り立たないんです
意外に簡単 俗世間は決断は難しいと思っている
感情で汚れているから
思考は曇っている 事実ではなく
感情を満たすことしか考えていないからなんです
俗世間では決断というのは勇気が必要だよとかね
なかなかできんよというのは
この感情で頭が曇ってるんですよ
ただそれだけのこと だから判断するときでも
感情を満たすことを考えているんですよ
儲かることやら楽しむことやら
その人は自分のものにすることやら
あの人をどうすれば私のものになるんでしょうかとかね
私の言いなりになるんでしょうか
そこしか考えてないんだから
判断難しいんですよ しかし
決断というのは意外に簡単です
決断なんかする必要もないと真理の立場で言えるのです
別に決 決断する必要もないんですよ
だって因果法則だから
もう全部決まってるんです
ちゃんとどんな判断をするべきかっていうことも
ここら辺は本当は説明しちゃうと結構難しいんですけどね
一応もう決まっておいてください
じゃあ次に行きます 因縁法則によって次の結果は決まっている
故に どのように判断するべきかも決まっている
これ例出してましたよ
例えば 火がついていたら消すしかないでしょうに
これ因縁で決まってます
火がついたらどんどん燃えますから
危険でしょうに だから自分が判断する
消すと 消そうかな どうしようかなとか冗談でしょうに
だから判断に困る必要ないんです
判断さえも自然に出てやるんですよ
例えば 子供が泣いたらもう慰めたり
なんとかしたりする 子供は泣いてるんだけどね
どうしましょうか あんたどう思いますか？とかね
考えるバカがいるんですかね
お腹が空いたら何かを食べる
これに図書館に行って本を調べるんですかね
このようなものですよ
人生っていうのは これ
なんで発見できんですかね
これ発見できたらあまりに簡単ですよ
火がついたら消すぐらいの感じで気楽に生きていられます
で 次どうなってるかと見てみましょう
で 他の判断の場合も だから今例で出した判断は単純でしょ
すべての判断は同じ 単純なんです
判断決断しなくてはならない状況があります
で 他の判断の場合は 例えばこの順番で書いています
判断しなくちゃいけないということにもう置かれちゃうんですね
その時は判断材料を見たらそちらに答えがあるんです
判断しなくちゃいけない
困った困ったじゃなくて
その状況を見たら答えがあるんですよ
例えば火が見たら消すって答えあるでしょ
そちらにまるっきり同じ
お腹が空いたら食べるって答えあるでしょうね
そちらに だから いかなる判断の場合でも
答えそちらにあるんですよ
これと探せばいいんです
それを見つけるためには
客観的に物事を見られる
訓練すればいい このくだらない妄想ではなくて
理性的に 客観的に物事を見る
その訓練すればいいんです
その能力があれば さらに心を楽にしておけば
問題を発見 なんでしょうかね
あ これ 2つですよ その能力もある
それからさらに心を楽にしておく
いわゆるリラックスして
いつでも穏やかで いつでも気楽にいるんですよ
心痛めてはいけないんですよ
心休めする方法というのは
妄想しないことなんです
で 私も電車に乗って ずーっと何も考えないんだと
こちらに来るまでと で
何も考えないでいるんですね
すごく楽なんです あ これやばいと思う
どんな駅か また次調べなくちゃいけないんですけどね
で そうやって楽にしておいてください
問題を発見した瞬間に答え見える
楽にしていると 客観性と心が楽にしている
瞬時に答え あ これっていう風に見えます
何のことなく出ます 答えは
ということで 神様助けてをやめましょうと
人 これは全部これなんです
人の顔を伺うとかね 顔色をね
長いものに巻かれるとかね
これすべて神様助けて論理なんですよ
責任 義務 捨てもうんぬんのごまかしなんですけどね
なんか打ち間違い まあごまかす
ごまかす 言い訳 それもやめてほしい
責任だからとかね これ義務だから
そんな言い訳じゃない
こんなのは責任でも義務でもなんでもないんです
問題に答えがあるんだから
そうやって言い訳しちゃうと間違えるんですよ
うちの子供だから そうすると間違うんですよ
感情で だから責任でも義務でも捨てもでも何でもないんです
ただ 問題に答えがあるだけ
このようなことで判断は見えません
そんなことで えーと 自分で決めて自信を持って行使するは
嘘で成り立たない こちらそれやったんで
どうすればいいんですか？と自分で決めて自信を持って
あの 行使すると実行するというの
なんかかっこいい言葉でしょ
本当はあんなのは嘘なんです
成り立ってないんです
そんなにストレス感じなくてもいいんですよ
問題には答えあるだけななんで
お腹が空いたら何か食べるということがあるだけであって
別に自信を持ってこうしなくたって
それしかないでしょうに
やることは 日が過ぎたら消すだけのことでしょうに
自信を何のために持つんですかね
だからそういうことを言おうとできなくなっちゃうんですよ
自信を持って自分で決めてちゃんと行使しようとか
これがダメハンディなんですよ
当たり前のことだからやればいいんですよ
事実は事実です 自分も他人もありません
世の中 それ書いたのは
この自分の見栄のために
褒めてもらうために判断してはいけないということ
これは自分の判断じゃないんです
例えば 日本の総理が何か判断するところ
何々さんの素晴らしかったという風に言いたくやると間違います
本当に日本でも昔の総理たちが素晴らしい判断をしてきたでしょうに
その人たちはそういう時はもう自分も他も何もなく
もう必死で仕事をしているんですよ
だから立派な判断をするんですよ
だから自分 現代人がいつでも自分を出すんですよ
タレント主義だから だからもうぐちゃぐちゃなんですね
そういうことでもう終わりと思いますけどね
まだありますか ここで裏の手もあります
今まで言ったことは難しいんだったら
まあ裏で手を裏で回す手もあります
これは簡単です  24時間も慈悲の気持ちで生きていれば
すべてうまくいく そう
今まで持ったものは全部それで解決する
常にすべての生命に対して慈しみを持つ
みんな幸せで平和でいてほしいと
ということで頑張ればもう簡単ですよ
不注意 うっかりミスはありません
そうなれば 不注意でうっかりミスというのは全然ないんです
たまにご判断しても大事には至らない
例えば人は優しい みんなのことを本気で
すべての生命のことを考えている
そこでたまたま間違っても
まあどうったことないってことになるんです
あ ごめんと言っただけでも終わるもんですよ
あ 失敗ね あ そうねって
それで終わっちゃうんです
なんてことをするのかってことになりません
だから すごい この裏の手っていうのはね
素晴らしいんですよ で
自分も楽しく幸福で生きて
他人にも楽しみ 幸福を与えることを目的にする
自分も楽しく幸福でいて
周りにも楽しみと幸福を与えて
みんな楽しませて生きてみる
それでリラックスして生きる
それからすごく楽にリラックスして生きる
すべてうまくいきます
それは裏の手 これ使ってください
今までの説明は ったら
はい まあもう一度押してください
で まあこれから私は言わなくてもわかると思います
人生って海で幸せに暮らしますよと
だから 今まで説明したこの裏の手でも作って
まあまあ こう まあそうやってうまくいっても
輪廻だから大物に食われますよ
だからやっぱり解脱しなきゃいけないんです
魚が来たのはそういうわけなんです
楽々なんですけど やっぱり大物に食われます
まあ一応それで終了だと思います
で 具体的な質問とかね
ディスカッションしたいものがあるならば
どうぞ はい  慈悲の気持ちっていうのと
あと感情的判断の違いのことなんですけど
慈悲の気持ちと感情っていうのは
どういうふうな形で違うのか
一応どうやって区別するのかって質問
慈悲の気持ちって温かいような気持ちで
それも感情のような気持ちっていう感情のように
見えますけど 感情重いんですよ
苦しいんですよ リミットがあるんですよ
例えば人を愛するにしたっても
みんな愛すること難しいんで
ややこしくてももう疲れるんですよ
でも慈悲っていうのはものすごく気楽なんです
すごく自由なんです どれほどの生命に慈悲を広げたっても
広げれば広げるほど楽なんです
感情っていうのはどんどん重くなるんです
その微妙な違いなんです
微妙じゃないんです すごいド派手な違いなんです
だからみんなもう幸せに生きてほしいという気持ちと
お前のことを本当に愛してるよっていうのはすごい違うでしょうに
だから感情の場合はやっぱりもう何て言いますか
カットしてセパレートしないと排他的でないとできないんですね
感情というのはいつでも一部を選んで一部を捨てるというね
怒りもそうでしょう 一部を選んで怒るんだからね
で 慈悲はそうじゃないんです
制限はない 壁はないんです
だから本当に慈悲だったら
ものすごく気楽感じるはず
我々は初心者で 慈悲と愛情
感情がごちゃだったら重さが感じるんですよ
慈悲の瞑想もやっぱりやりきれない
やりにくいなとかね やりにくく感じたら
それは慈悲というよりも感情なんです
例えば電車に乗って みんな幸せであってほしい
でもあいつはなんか気持ち悪いと思っちゃうと
本当はもうもう感情 慈悲じゃないんですよ
そうすると重くなるんですね
そこら辺でチェックしてください
うん ではまた  ですけど
慈悲の瞑想の時に私を嫌いな人たちも幸せでありますようにとか
私を嫌っている人たちもとか
そんなようなことがあるんですけど
そういう時にわざわざ言葉だけと思って
そういう気持ちになるっていうふうにして思ってるんですけど
私を嫌いな人々とか 私を嫌って誰が私のことを嫌ってるかとか
あんまり考えられないので
そういうのは何なんですか？それはこう
ただ私を例えば嫌っていようとも
幸せでありますようにっていう心の状態でやればいいんでしょうか
それはなんで入れてるかというと
この慈しみは感情とずいぶん誤解しやすいんだから
明確に区別してもらうために
ブッダお釈迦様が入れてる言葉なんです
そこでそれはもう削除はできない
例えば嫌いな人も幸せ
なんだこれ バカバカらしいんじゃないかとか思ったりするでしょうし
あるいはなんでわざわざと嫌いな人まで入れるんでしょうかと思っちゃうでしょ
それだったらもうアウトで
あれ感情なんですよ 慈悲じゃないんですよ
だからその葛藤を心に起こるということは
もう明確に知った上で入れてるんです
でもあえて我々にはハンディつけてるんですよ
落とし穴 それでうまくそれは合格しちゃうと
完全たる慈悲っていうのは現れてきます
それでやがて嫌いな人
当たり前でしょではないかと
みんな幸せになりたいでしょうにと
何考えてるんですかという気持ちになるともうOKです
私を嫌ってる人です まあその連中も楽しみだから
これいいんじゃないんですか？とかね
自分のことをいちいち嫌ったりいじめたりしてとかね
元気でやれと という気持ちになってくると
もう OK なんですね それで感情ではなく
本当の慈悲になっているんです
だから これはこのすごい強いなガイドラインです
この嫌いな人も嫌ってる人もっていうことはわかりました
うん  やってみなきゃわからないっていうのは
失敬の方の用語で正しい使い方だっていう風に仰ってたんですけど
例えば判断するときに必要なデータがちゃんと集まってなくて
まあどっちに転ぶかわからないけども
自分のそのシミュレーションの方が正しいか正しくないかっていうことを検証するために
実験的にやってみなきゃわからないっていうケースは大にして出てくるんですけども
そういう時に大体迷う
頭が比較的正常な場合とか
そういう時にこそ迷うと思うんですけど
うんうんうん  それは私はちょっとポイントを入れようと思ったんですけど
できないし このレイアウトではね
あの 物質的な世界ではいいんですよ
シミュレーションでできます
いくらかはね しかし 人件費
何でしたか？あれは人体実験してはいけないんです
恐ろしいんです 人間がこれ人体実験に使ってるでしょ
すっごく汚いんですよ
仏教の場合でも あんたこの瞑想をやってみれば？とか
今個人的な悩みがあるんだから言ってますけどね
無責任で言うんじゃないよと
すごく昔怒ったこともあります
これ明らかに人体実験だから
どうどう瞑想してとかね
そうやってもいい加減な瞑想指導士とかいますけど
ものそれは明らかに人体実験なんです
だから 特に仏教の場合は
この仏教は厳しく ものすごい心を育てる方法を教えてるんだから
もう医学よりも何よりもすごく緊張して気をつけて一言葉でも言わなくちゃいけない
だからこの たとえ仏教の世界にしたっても
もう人体実験的では良くないんです
仏教はものすごく断ってる
お釈迦様もなぜお釈迦様は如来というのかと
なぜタタハガという 私はやってから言ってるんだ
言ってるんだよと ヤタカーリ
タタワーディー 自分で人体実験はどうっていうことはないんだからね
それはやって結果得て言ってるんだよと
次にヤタワーディ タタカーリ
私が言うことはその通りになるんだよと
だから実験じゃないんです
だからタターガタと言うんだよと
如来と言うんだよと だからこのやってみなきゃわからないってことはもうある時もありますよ
それはやっぱりデータが足らないってことなんですよ
結局は 特に科学の場合は
現代科学になってくると
結構シミュレーションというものも必要になったりもします
で それは科学が発展した時点でデータが足らなくなってるんです
今は 本当はデータがしっかりあるはずなんですけど
科学の発展過程に考えて
帰ってみるとデータがないにも関わらず決めなくちゃいけない羽目になってるんです
昔の科学と今は違うんだからね
昔はすごい まあすごくごく普通なことを研究すればよかったんだからね
今は素粒子やらあれやこれやとか
もうもう何もわけもわからないことをやらなくちゃあかんでしょうし
その場合はデータがないんですよ
特に宇宙科学はいろいろほとんどデータがないでしょう
だから全部シミュレーションでやったりする
それはそれで まあもう勝手でいいんですけど
人には迷惑ないんだからね
人体実験では絶対ダメってことです
そういうふうなことをやり始める前から考えれば
そういうことは割に合わんからやらん方がいいっていうのが答えになるかもしれないですけども
それはケースバイケースでわかりますからね
割に合うか合わないかということはね
あと その判断をするべき時を本当はせないかんのにせずにうっかりやり忘れてしまって
それでシチュエーションが流れてしまってっていうことがよくあるんですけども
そういうまあ仕方がないので
ではないんで それ私は扱ってますが
その問題 妄想にふけってるんですね
妄想にふける  で この浅井カルチャーの講演で出したお釈迦様の言葉があって
これを今日もそれって置いたんですけど
もうレイアウトができた
自動的に出来上がっちゃうと入らなくなっちゃったんです
愚か者って何なのかと
愚か者っていうのは 将来の重さ
責任の重さを運ぶんだけど
現在の責任の重さを運ばないんだと
だから バーローアナタんバランワハティ
まだ起きてもないことについてえらい心配する
起きてることについては無関心であると
だから判断するのは現在
今のことでしょうに それがうっかりしないで別なことに頭が合ったっていうことなんです
あるいはこれからのことで心配していたんでしょう
それは愚か者の定義なんですね
仏教では で だからそれは一般的で
みんなわかってる言葉で妄想ということで
まあ今に今関係ないことは考えているんですね
それで判断できなくなっちゃうんです
それで時間が経過しちゃうと
もうどうにもならないことになります
いや もっと難しい質問ではなくてもいいんだから
生々しい質問でもいいんです
生々しい質問するのは皆様に簡単ですけど
私にとっては答えるのは難しいんですよ
専門的な論理的なことっていうのは
私にとってはなんともことないんです
ですから 私もちょっといじめたいと思って
ごく普通の生々しい質問とかね
実践的な具体的な人生の問題とかね
とにかくこの判断というのは
この車がエンストしていて
どうすればというのは具体物質的なもので
こんな問題ないんですよ
判断というのは この生きる上の判断なんですよ
だから命に関わる判断について我々語ってます
さっきの慈悲の瞑想とかちょっと似てるんですけれども
あのクリスチャンの人たちが戦争があると
そこの国に平和が来て
神様に祈ったりしてるんですけどもね
仏教ではそういう時 どういう形で祈るの？祈らない
祈らない 戦争をやめなさいと言うんです
うん 人殺しながら祈るっていうことはちょっと理解できない
戦争を引き起こすのはそういう方々でしょうし
祈りさえ矛盾でしょう
結局はすべて神様が決めるんだからね
全知全能だから 神様がそれ知らないはずがないんです
これで祈ると神様馬鹿にしているんです
全知全能の神様を 大きなお世話ですよ
祈るんだったら なんか自分に何かくれと言ってもいいんですけどね
神様はこれこれぐらいをくれてるんですけど
俺がもうちょっと欲しいと
という祈りはいいんだけど
世界平和の祈りとかね
あんま意味がないんです
しかし 悪いとは言いませんだけど
みんなそういう世界中大勢の人々はね
平和を祈願する気持ちがあれば
人間の力では平和になる可能性はありますから
みんなで平和を祈願した方がいいんです
力強く 具体的に 神に祈るということは具体的じゃないんです
正直かもしれませんよ
そういう人々は でもあれはもう屁理屈で馬鹿正直なんです
馬鹿正直はどうでも役に立たんだからね
だから仏教だったら行動するんです
うん 祈ったりはしません
で 例えば自分の国でもいろんなところでいろんな国際トラブルがあった時
昔と昔は結構口うるさかったんだからね
であったら別に祈りするっていうことは全くなく
すぐ抗議文句文句を書いて
はっきりこれはやめなさいと
っていうだけで みんなで祈りましょうっていうのは
それはもう もう意味っていうかね
あまり仏教は論理的だからね
まああんまり成り立たないんです
だから仏教だったらはっきりとやめなさいということで
一人で聞いてくれないんだったらみんなで言う
国のみんなで一緒に言う
それも聞いてくれないんだったら
もう隣の隣の国もみんなで一緒に言いましょうと
そういうふうに行動で平和を作るんです
この場合でも イラク戦争
アメリカを独立独立孤立させた方が良かったのにね
みんな集めて で 一人でやってくださいと
できないんですよ そうするとフセインさんの問題も解決できる
フセインさんにも言えますから
あんたもいい加減にしなさいよと
守ってあげたんだからということを言えたのにね
それで自分にも良い結果で
他人にも良い結果で みんなにも良い結果で出ていきますよ
だから正しい判断だったらね
だからこの基準というのは
どんな国際スケールでもどこでも使用できるんですよ
でも 仏教の話は世界では通じませんだからね
しょうがないんですけどね
ということです うん では
まあ他質問ございませんでしょうかね
お腹が空いて質問のところじゃないかもしれませんね
はい あ はいはい こちら
参加させていただいたんですけど
五戒分って今日の判断の判断の話ですなんですけど
五戒の中にはいろいろありますけど
僕はお酒がすごく好きで
多分今日のお話でもやめない教団に入らせていただいたんですけど
やめないと思うんですけど
綺麗な女の子と喋るのも大好きなんですって
今日も実は夜中の 3時ぐらいまで飲んでたんですけど
そういう人間っていうのは
まあその例えばお酒をやめるとか
そういった場所に行かないとか
もちろんそういったことも大事なんですけど
自分でもそういう人間になれるかどうかわからないので
ちょっと修行になる うんうん
どうなっちゃうのか  ああ
まあまあ 別にね あの まあ本当にそういう単純な質問です
私には答えるのはすごく難しいんですよ
私は困る質問ですけど
まず仏教の立場っていうのはね
諦めなよと 人生っていうのはね
せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
もう人間を乗り越えることもできるんだよと
神様も誰でも一切の存在を乗り越えることできる能力を持って生まれたんだよと
これはね くだらないことで終わるんでしょうかとね
体の刺激だけで 体っていうのはもう腐っちゃうし
年は取るしね 病気になってやがて腐って死んでしまうでしょうしね
そんな体のためにこんな大事な宝物をね
使いますか？っていう仏教の道徳的な考え方なんですよ
ですから 諦めるなよっていうことなんですね
もう誰にでもできるんだという何でも
しかし 個人個人ではやっぱり欲しいんだから
好きだからという弱みがあります
で これもじわじわと客観的に理解していくと
やっぱりダメっていうことがわかるでしょうとわかると思います
何でもいきなり一発で理解できるということはないんだからね
ゆっくり頑張ってくださいということなんです
まだまだひどい目に遭ってないだけだと思いますけどね
え？だとまあ そういうことだと思いますけど
まあ例で言えば 高速道路で車は暴走している
俺ってすごいなと思ってあって
まだまだどこかにぶつかってないだけで
ぶつかっちゃうとやっぱり痛いとわかりますからね
だから だからぶつかるまでやれと言っちゃうと不親切ですよ
我々はね 人はひどい目に遭うまで待つというね
それはさせないんですよ
最初からも気をつけなさいと
ということで まあゆっくり頑張ればわかると思います
はい  目の前の現実でどうしてもやらなければならないこととかがあるのに
それに対してどうもどうしてもやる気がしなかったり
興味が出なかったりするのはもうどうさまとか
もう  うん これどちらにもなりますけどね
チャンともなる場合もありますけどね
別なことをやりたいという欲があると
これ目の前のことをできなくなっちゃうし
こんなのやりたくないよと気持ちになっちゃうと動作でしょうしね
もう難しい わからないと
もう早く終わりたいという気持ちになると
もうでしょうしね だからどちらにもなりますから
その場でその場でどちらかと決めないとね
例えば出来っこはないとかね
そんなたくさん仕事という場合は
やる気がないことだから
そちらも謀反になるんですよ
だから何も考えないで
ものすごく気楽に もう淡々とやっちゃった方がいつでもすぐそちらに答えあるんだからね
もう意外に簡単にいけるんです
例えば会社でこれやりな
すごい膨大な仕事をしていったりする
時間リミットもあるんだよと
そんなに気にする必要ないんですよ
自分が 1 秒も無駄にしないで仕事をするんだったら
自然法則によってこの 1 秒でどれぐらい仕事かということはあるんですよ
命令する側はくだらない計算したっても
それはそちらの因果法則の失敗であって
世の中は自分でも他人でもないんです
例えば目の前にたくさん仕事があっても
1 秒間でどれぐらい仕事あるかっていうことはもうはっきりしていますからね
だからそんなにストレス感じる必要もないし
やりたくないこんなことをどうしようとも思う必要はないんです
もう淡々と気楽にやるっていうことは答えなんですけどね
その時はもうでもない
もうも何でもないんですよ
すごく冷静でクールでいることなんです
鼻歌でも歌いながら じゃあやりましょうという感じで
はい  はいはい 判断を判断した時にですね
心が高ぶることがあるんですけど
例えば お酒を飲まれたりとかした時にですね
はい 判断をして断った
その後 感情的に相手に対して怒りというか
失礼になってしまったりとか
それその判断に対して感情が高ぶるっていうんですか
心の中が  高ぶる  ような状態になることが多いんですけれども
うん はい まあこれ感情高ぶったりするということは
この裏の手を使うんですよ
裏の手を使ってないんですよ
で 酒に誘われたら断る場合は
慈しみで判断するんです
そうするとすっごくうまくいくんですよ
君にとっては本当に楽しいなのにね
せっかく仲良くしようとね
私にも話しかけてもくれたのに
あの 本当にどうしようねと
私はもう酒はやめてるしとか
なんとかとかね せっかくやめたことは
自分でも優柔不断にはなりたくないしとか
なんとかとか そんなふうな話でいうと
向こう側がはい わかりました
申し訳ないということで
向こうは出ていくんであって
万事うまくいくんですよ
あるいはじゃあだったら別なことしましょうということに来るんですよ
だから断ると言った途端
仲良くすることもなくなっちゃうんでしょうしね
だから答え 3番目の答えもありますよ
それは慈悲があると この 3番目も出てきて
全部うまくいっているなんて
向こうの気持ちもちゃんと叶って
こちらの気持ちも叶ってて
いや 良かったんではないかと
ですから いつでもこの裏の手を使わないとできないんです
慈悲ということ そういうふうに頑張ってください
裏の手がなかったんだから
ちょっと怒りが出たり
高ぶったりはします なぜ慈悲に裏の手というんでしょうかというと
別にわざわざ慈悲の瞑想する場面じゃないんですよ
もう判断する場面だから
だから これには私はわざと裏の手という言葉を使うんです
決断力ってどんな人に
決断力ってどんな人に必要なんですか？ これはみんなに必要ですよ
決断力なかったらもう人生ダメになっちゃうんだからね
だから小さい時からもうちゃんと何が自分にとって良いかと
みんなに お父さんにも
他の兄弟にも みんなにも
何がいいかということを自分一人で
あ これはいいんだからやるぞというふうに決めなくちゃいけないんです
だから言われると気持ち悪いでしょ
これやれやれやれって言うとね
やりたくもないでしょ
だから決断力っていうのは
子供からみんなに必要なんです
自分で決めてやるともうかっこいいし
やりやすいしね もう苦しいとも感じない
つまらない退屈やとも感じないしね
そういうわけで みんなに必要です
うん わかったんですか？うん